Donald Trump gave a very strange
interview to a guy named Joe Pags I
don't know who Joe Pags is but he really
likes Trump and during this interview
Donald Trump went back to the story of
the FBI might have planted the documents
to frame me or they might have stolen
documents wait the FBI planted or they
stole they brought in or they took out
and if that's the case how did you know
to telepathically declassify the very
documents that the FBI planted none of
it makes any sense but Trump is back on
this train once again and they wouldn't
let us have lawyers there they wouldn't
let us have any representation so who
knows what was planted who knows what
was put in there who knows what was
taken out and you know if you look at
the group it's a largely radical left
run narrow right and you look at it it's
all EX they're quite frankly Communists
folks this was generally speaking a
really wild interview Trump is doing
very minor shows by phone not even
taking the time to get in front of a
video camera that's the theme
desperation to be interviewed anywhere
that will have him he's welcome on this
program Anytime by the way let's listen
to a little bit more of this Joe Pags
interview and you'll notice it's not
exactly hard hitting
you're beyond very good so I was a
television news anchor in Michigan for
eight years I I was on the streets as a
reporter I know that's paid very well
they love you there and I'll never
forget what you did in 2016 at about
three o'clock in the morning in Grand
Rapids and about 5 000 people showed up
to cheer you on as you wanted to beat
Hillary Clinton why is Michigan so
important to you yes
tough question by the way
I just seemed to
September the state I was given the man
of the year award Joe years ago like
that's a lie
that's a lie first question first answer
that's a lie this is old ground Trump
has repeatedly claimed that he won
Michigan's Man of the Year award the
award does not exist
seven seconds in
Trump has already told a lie 11 or 12
years ago and I used to tell them why
are you countries like Mexico to take
your cars your automobile manufacturing
business away and I don't know I've
always felt that Michigan just let so
much get away it's got such assets that
it just lets so much go away I mean it
anyway so it's just lies and lies and
lies let's just jump you know randomly
into the middle of the interview just to
get a little bit more of the flavor Mr
President the only time we found out
anything that may or may not have been
at Mar-A-Lago was after they took it and
started leaking it out so what do you
think the game is here yeah
you know what you just hard-hitting no
like why did you have the documents it
is very interesting nobody ever heard
any leaks or anything any problems and
then all of a sudden when they take it
out and they put it into Nara or
wherever they have it all of a sudden
things started leaking as the documents
started it's all leaking everywhere so a
very strange interview riddled with lies
as usual and the theme is
nobody's even having Trump on in terms
of the serious networks it's Joe Pags
and real America's voice and right side
broadcasting wild times and just imagine
what's going to happen over the next
week as all of these different legal
issues come to a head we'll take a quick
break and be back with Jesse singer
right after this
right now many of us are asking
ourselves what's the best way to help
the people affected by the recent
hurricanes and the truth is giving them
cash is one of the best things you can
do because cash is so cost effective
when you give families cash you're also
empowering them to choose for themselves
how to best improve their situation and
I've talked before about our sponsor
give directly give directly is a
non-profit that just lets donors like
you send cash directly to families who
need it the most give directly is a
great organization I've been following
for years a lot of their focus is on
impoverished families in Africa but
right now give directly is also allowing
you to send cash directly to families
impacted by hurricanes Ian and Fiona
during Hurricane Ian more than two and a
half million people were ordered to
leave their homes expenses are rising
they need food shelter Transportation
hurricane Fiona hit Puerto Rico on
September 18th more than 12 000 people
displaced the island is still in a state
of emergency and people need help visit
give directly.org Pacman to learn more
and send money directly to someone who
needs it the link is down below